when i first came to l.a i just assumed
people were going to tell me like you
got to get some sun and lose some weight
no one did i have about 13 agents and 12
managers right and then neil brennan
is the straight shooting la guy that was
just like
do you remember yeah i said uh
i said like you're fat
you can't be fat out here you just can't
you have to be like
this skinny
if you want to be on camera you're
either skinny yeah or like
crazy fat like cartoon fat
yeah castable fast castable like when
they cut to you they got to go i like
this got this fat guy yeah yeah i just
have my mouth under a sock like eating
spaghetti
and then they cut to you at the end of
scenes like guys wait up
very very skinny though i'm not doing
i didn't know it was going to go this
way you don't have to go you're like
zero percent but you're like
too far donnie wahlberg in sixth sense
remember yeah
remember andy